could be bigger than Watergate more big
trouble for Joe Biden the FBI searching
a third property must be nice in their
hunts for classified documents this time
it was a beach house the bureau looking
under every boogie board for secret
materials no docs with classified
markings were discovered but had written
notes from his time as VP they were
taken the search comes two weeks after
Biden spent the weekend there relaxing
and definitely definitely not
instructing Hunter to burn documents
that seemed like a big deal
but don't worry the White House Council
says this was a planned search
today uh in a planned consensual search
with the justice department they went
through the Rehoboth Beach house and no
classified Marx documents were found
this is consistent I think with the
president from the very beginning of
having total cooperation with the
justice department as it goes through
this ongoing investigation we've been
pretty transparent from the very
beginning with providing information as
it occurs throughout this process you
know we have released probably thousands
of words of statements from the
president's personal attorney and the
White House counsel's office about the
process that has been undertaken here
total cooperation
well about that trademark White House
transparency we just found out that the
FBI searched the Penn Biden Center back
in November but I guess they forgot to
tell us and then there's this top
Republican James Comer says the National
Archives was blocked from telling the
public when classified docs were first
found
right before the National Archives came
in they handed us a letter from the
Department of Justice informing them and
us that the general counsel for the
National Archives wasn't allowed to say
anything about the Biden documents there
are only two people that could have
given him those orders and that's either
the Department of Justice with Merrick
Garland or the white house with Joe
Biden um judge why is it so important
that they have to keep saying total
cooperation isn't that meaningless what
else are they going to do well what else
they can do is they can have Kareen
Jean-Pierre come out and say the
president has been clear the president
has been clear here's the problem Kareem
Jean-Pierre who speaks for the president
constantly says he's been clear but
always says the same thing I refer you
to the White House counsel or to the
Department of Justice the truth is that
since all this happened they've had six
different people come in to talk about
other issues like somewhat curving from
the Pentagon or someone to talk about
covet do they bring in someone else to
talk about what we want to know and by
the way they have been so
non-transparent in this because on
November 2nd when we when we didn't know
about it we didn't hear about this until
January 10th but on November 2nd that's
when they first find stuff at the Penn
Biden Center and then they found stuff
on December 20th but we don't hear about
it until January 9th now today three
months later later we hear that oh they
found stuff at the Penn Biden Center
that we didn't tell you about and three
months later just in case they didn't
have a chance to get rid of everything
we're going to let the FBI go in and
search Rehoboth the beach house I mean
this is this is outrageous and the the
truth as it goes to these reports from
the individuals in the white houses they
could say it's a planned search they can
say we've said thousands of words
they've said nothing you know Dana we at
the start of this said the the what was
classified might be meaningless who
knows that's not what we're concerned
with we're concerned with the fact that
they are complete transparency the way
they they treated Trump versus this what
do you think about it I I I just imagine
all the miscalculations that went into
this from the very beginning we the the
most transparent thing is how
transparent they are at hiding it yeah
so so they we don't know they know
before the election they don't tell
anybody they know before they appoint a
special counsel to president Trump they
don't say anything they knew about the
uh well then that oh and then this one
they say that this was a planned search
well it was planned two weeks after the
president got to spend a weekend there
uh two weeks ago that's kind of bizarre
yeah and why didn't they tell the Press
office that's kind of strange too like
how is that transparent I don't get it
and also if who can tell the National
Archives you're not allowed to talk
about it to me there's only two people
right there it would be the justice
department or the white house so let's
that could we have some transparency and
find out who told the archives are not
allowed to say that and the truth is all
of these documents could be innocuous it
could be just like sometimes there is
over classification and maybe the
documents say oh you know we went there
was a briefing paper before we went went
to aipac one year and here's some
information in 2007 about Israel and the
posture then but that is it's been
overtaken by events it's not important
anymore but they've made a mountain out
of a mohill and the president has said
oh I can't look at the documents because
the lawyers told me not to I also think
that that's based on my conversations
with Andy McCarthy uh that not true like
you you could look at him as
commander-in-chief you're responsible
for National Security and they could
have put an end to this right away and
they decided not to and what's
interesting is they've always tried to
say that the hunter Biden laptop story
is just about Hunter Biden and then
they're trying to say these documents
are just about
by Joe Biden but is that true yeah we
don't know and you and you it would they
always wonder why people are so
conspiratorial why do people think this
way it was because you're not being
transparent and all you say is that you
are yeah and you got you you have a
crack addicted dude with questionable
dealings in the same place where
classified documents are while he's
dealing and operating with a foreign
adversary so it's like it's not much of
conspiracy to connect those dots Geraldo
this is an incredibly timely Scandal
right when he decides to run for
re-election which member of the deep
state is setting him up the same people
who went after Trump or Nixon huh maybe
maybe it was them uh this is the
Incredible Shrinking Scandal as I've
said there's absolutely no there there
uh we've been talking about this around
and around and around and now Vice
President Pence of course famously is uh
is involved in the in the so-called
Scandal this is totally political
retribution this is all all you know a
reaction or uh but from her you know a
fight back from uh but the Republicans
really how would the Republicans know
this stuff why is it Greg that we're
we're talking about a document scanner
when there are zero evidence that
National Security has been compromised
and we're not talking about the paycheck
uh Protection Program and the billions
of dollars that were wasted squandered
stolen over a hundred billion they
thought it was stolen why aren't we I
think we did talk about it here why
don't we in a bite not an artisan manner
why don't we go after something the
American people care about they don't
care this is a this is the librarian
scolding the people who kept the books
overdue it has nothing to do with
anything in American life not one family
watching this today is affected one iota
by this phony Scandal so you're not
you're not offended by the fact that
Hunter Biden is around collecting bags
of money from countries that his father
has a direct policy that is the story
you have a junkie uh you know you're
only as happy as you're unhappy you know
what you know and the bidens have a very
unhappy child I don't care about that
what I care about is the president of
the United States having a son who is
deciding what countries to take Millions
from paying his father
because the son had access to those
documents he said he was paying fifty
thousand dollars a month to live there
is there one he had access all of this
why did he need access one person
because at the same time he was trying
to get on the board of barisma and he
needed information from his father who
was the energy Point man on in Ukraine
zero relevance the American people all
right Jesse wrap it up
tell us why this is important
don't points are all the
sees shrinkage I don't see shrinkage
this scandal's a grower
my sources in Rehoboth yes so when Joe
was there over the weekend he had a fire
there was smoke coming out of the
chimney I'm not saying he used the
classified documents as kindling I'm not
saying that but maybe I am and here's
how I know it's more about classified
documents because they seized materials
and notes from the beach house if
they're only looking for classified
documents why are they taking materials
and notes from the beach house and also
when they went to the Wilmington House
they took classified documents and they
took handwritten notes to-do lists I
have an idea and a quick photo quick
idea Geraldo fine make it quick find
them money if they keep documents and
they're not supposed to have them find
them just the same way a librarian you
know makes you baby sugar brother can
Pony up the dope for the fine he's
paying his back taxes too when does the
FBI let the suspect spend the weekend at
the crime scene yeah it's crazy
OJ why don't you go rest back at Bundy
uh before our investigators get there
you look tired so the FBI could be an
outrageous comparison totally but it's
fitting they have been the FBI has been
to Joe's office to Joe's house to Joe's
beach house and you're saying there's
nothing going on they're squeezing this
guy they put him in the white house and
they can take him out of the White House
you talked about who is that deal who's
they the same people that got him the
Deep State also Hunter is shopping
classified documents for cash you have
them in the laptop going to The Aluminum
Company hey guys I have business
intelligence on Russian oligarchs I'll
hand it over for fifty five thousand
dollars did you know that Hunter button
was a Russian expert did you know he was
an artist I didn't know he's a real
Renaissance Man Geraldo and where is he
getting access to Top Secret
intelligence that he's selling to Blue
Star Strategies sources his bartender my
source is the laptop Rehoboth Beach it's
a laptop great bars down there they're
the ones who suggested through the media
that Donald Trump had nuclear secrets
exactly in his documents so we're being
very kind we're saying these documents
are probably innocuous but why are you
making such a big deal out of it well
you know yeah it was fake again
he was using them to get on that board
in barisma to get hired to collect money
for the Biden family
hi winner Brian Kilmeade I want you to
do me a favor I want you to click to to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now